بداية القط
أ
[موسيقى]
أهلا
ما هي النعمة التي قابلتها؟
سعيدة
إنه الباب الأمامي حسنًا الآن هذا السؤال
عندما تكون وحيدًا لأن هناك الكثير
أنا لا أفكر في الأمر ، كنت أعلم أنه لا يناسبني
هناك بار للنزول ، مثل الخروج من بوو
لن تأتي آخر عجلة من المعتاد ، حلم جوهرة
شارب في وقت لاحق بيدرو غطاء المحفظة
أنا أحب السنانير و px و المنعطفات
بادئ ذي بدء ، أنا فخور جدًا
قم بزيارة دبي لأول مرة
بسبب ذلك ، أشعر ببعض الغرابة الآن
لقد كان كبيرًا ، هذا المعرض الكبير آخر مرة
أيضًا ، أضعها جانبًا لأداء في بيئة.
معتقدًا أنه لا يمكنك دراسة الدراجات ،
سأنهيها وأعود
ماركمان هانك فوم نوع يجعل الحاجبين يتساقطان
دعونا نحسن الأمن ، الرعب الرائد عزه موبا في الليل
إذا لم تكن مرتاحًا ، فأنت طائر جيد
هل يمكنني إنهاء طبقة التظليل؟
كاشا بسي ، لا إصلاح لغة أو أرز
لقد تجنبت نفس الشيء الذي أبصقته
طيب القانون
بعد مرور الكثير من الوقت
لكني أشعر أن الوقت كثير جدًا
أعطيها لأنها تبدو قصيرة مرة أخرى.
هناك جزء غريب ، وهناك الكثير
لقد تغيرت الأمور كثيرًا بخصوص الكيبوب
يستفد
هناك الكثير من هذه الأشياء في البيئة.
تغير
كيفية اتباعها والتكيف معها
لا يزال رائعًا
ها ، اعتقدت أنه سيكون على هذا النحو
وقبل كل شيء نبات الكبر ب كبير جدًا
الحب هو
نفس k
موسيقى البوب ​​كعضو في Caper ،
أنا ممتن وأنا سعيد
أوو
[موسيقى]
خذ براون تاو إلى خان بايثون
طوال الوقت ، بدأت القضبان في الرفع بأغلبية ساحقة
Galbi عندما لا أجني أي أموال
من اليوم الثاني فصاعدًا ، هناك عدد غير قليل
نجمة كبسولة اللثة أو غطاء لين
تم التوصية بـ Bino لـ 8 أشخاص.
نعم ، أشعر بالقلق خلال فترة التوقف الطويلة
القليل
في كثير من الحالات
ما نوع الألبوم الذي سيصدر ويقول المعجبون ذلك
أحب الألبوم وهو جيد جدًا
عندما تنتهي جنسيا
أي نوع من الاطمئنان هو القلق الذي شعرت به؟
كانت فرصة عظيمة للتغيير.
فكرت في الأمر ، ومرة ​​أخرى مع المعجبين
بعض الأعضاء المميزين لدينا
الكثير من الأشياء مثل الترابط
لأنه ألبوم أشعر به
لأكون صريحًا ، أنا مبالغ فيه بعض الشيء.
من BEAST إلى Highlight
خلال الألبوم
معنى الألبوم "The Blowing" هو Kamen
اعتقدت أنه سيكون الأكبر
سوف احاول
[موسيقى]
آه ، الطفل الصعب أصبح منفعلًا
لقد التقيت بالسرطان وحصلت على دروع ثقيلة من هذا الوقت فصاعدًا
فيجي بيرد كيكا شيلبي أيوم بيك سيونغ وون
اكتب مرة واحدة وأي درس 1 أ
يهز بوا قوس حلو ومر لا بن
توجو الغوغاء
أفكر في لوحة إعلانات ابن الجنين في سيول
في الواقع ، سد المروحة عندما كنا في الجيش
2 انفجار
لم نكن في الخارج منذ ذلك الحين.
لم أملك قط
تعال إلى دبي بهذه الفرصة الرائعة
بعد كل شيء ، كنت قادرًا على الأداء أولاً ، في الواقع
انا سعيد للغاية
و
بالأمس كان الوقت الذي تجول فيه الاثنان قليلاً
فهمتك
ذهبت إلى دبي الرمل بعد وقت طويل
استمتع بوقتك وتعرف على مقاعد البدلاء
أكلت ما أه ما هو الوضع نعم ماذا
نفس
أه ، القائمة الدقيقة الآن مخططة بدقة
لا أتذكر ، لكني كنت آكل طعامًا عربيًا.
من المحتمل أن يكون هذا هو Park Coding
لماذا 4 ماذا ، بالنظر إلى الكسر 5
4 قضوا وقتًا رائعًا
أوه الآن كان حلما
أعتقد أن لدي عقل مماثل.
كنت أرغب حقًا في السفر إلى الخارج.
4 أردت أن أتحدث
في الحالات التي يكون فيها من المستحيل
من الجيد جدًا أن تكون قادرًا على أن نكون معًا مثل هذا اليوم
اشعر براحة
أوه نعم ، أنا أيضًا أسافر إلى الخارج ، لكنني اليوم
بالأمس واليوم تمنيت مثل هذه أمنية
انه جيد جدا
4 آه ، أنا مسافر
كنت سأمنحك بعض السفر إلى الخارج
إنه مثل ، بعد التسريح من الجيش مباشرة
فقط لا تفعل شيئا
اه 5 أردت فقط المغادرة
نعم
ش 9
أكل و اشرب
أنا فقط أريد أن أفعل ذلك بدون تفكير
اعتقدت
بعد الخروج من المستشفى الآن
لذلك ، لا بد لي من القيام بذلك مرة أخرى
لأنه لا يزال هناك مثل هذا الوقت
لا يمكن إرسال 4
م
أوو
[موسيقى]
بابا دالا عبارة عن فطيرة فطيرة بيندر
1 مافيا تمتص الراهب البوبي
أنا كلب مع بقرة كوم mobashiro
آه آه Propaoke وعاء الماء insusu
سوف أكل نصف نحن ioi
دليل صحي أحمر خبيث
لا أعرف ، ولكن بمجرد أن نفعل ذلك
الصداقة عميقة جدا و
أوه ، عندما ذهبنا إلى جدول البث ، الآن بعضنا البعض
أثناء تبادل النكات
اه ارخي الاجواء المتوترة والطاقة
لا يوجد شيء جديد وهذا شيء جيد
الطاقات التي تخرج بشكل جيد على المسرح
مثل الكلب ، شخصيا ، أنا الآن
نفسك وما تجيده ، و
عن قلة الدقائق
كما تعلم ، حاول أن تفعل هذا بنفسك
رؤية كل أصدقائي ، أحاول جاهدا
شيئا فشيئا ، شيئا فشيئا ، لدينا
ألا يوجد تمييز؟
وأود أن
Dongwook هي أم جيدة مليئة بالعرب
إنه قريب من الكافا الكبيرة
مع عرض مامو مثل هذا ، طفت حول الرحمة
أين العرب ، كبار السن وكئيب
يا متجري منخفض
أوه ، أحد ألقابي المفضلة
انها أيضا
أوه ، وكما قلت من قبل ،
كنت أتجول حول العمة توفا أمس.
مرحبًا بالنظر إلى السكان المحليين أه هذا
ربما نحن مثل الهواء دون آخر
فكرة أن الدم يتدفق
فعلت
بالأمس ، جاءني مواطن آخر إلي في دبي
لم أتمكن من العثور عليه ، لذلك سألت عن الطريق مرة أخرى.
الأمر ليس كذلك ، فالأمر ليس كذلك
أنت تقول إنها ليست كوريا
أتذكر أن
نعم ، هم متشابهون إلى حد ما
لم تشعر به
[موسيقى]
Ai فريد أيضًا في هذا البناء ، نعم
[صفق]
أوه ، USC بعيد ، فقط من الأعلى
استمع وانطلق في ذلك الشهر
مثل كل ما تفعله بي ، فقط عندما تدفع شيئًا آخر
لا تذهب إلى المنزل ، هل يمكنني القيام بذلك في اليوم الثاني؟
لا يوجد قناع قرصنة بيضة جديدة
آه
رأيت القليل من بشار
Show Lateran Hard Lens ASCII حزن
الابتسامة التي أمامنا نحيفة ، وتجنيب القلعة
رأيت الجمعية الوطنية أدناه.
كان هذا أول شيء أفعله بعد إنهاء خدمتي العسكرية.
الجدول هو ملك عائلة Bongmyeong.
لا يوجد جدول زمني
لذا فإن العبء كبير جدًا ، فلا يوجد
القواعد أو شيء من هذا القبيل
في ذلك الوقت ، كان من الصعب جدًا تحقيق 8 انتصارات متتالية.
قوي في المكان
حقا
جسديًا ، أعددت نفسي بشدة.
أعتقد أنني فعلت ذلك ، لكن في ذلك الوقت ، كان هناك الكثير
الراحة لأولئك الذين يكافحون
لقد عرضت عليك الكثير من المراحل.
ثم ، في نفس الوقت ، أنا
مرتاح
أعتقد أنه كان مثل هذا الوقت
لم أستطع سماعك بينما كنت في الجيش
اكتب صوت 100 الثاني مرة أخرى
لهولاء
شيء ثمين للغاية يمكنني أن أخبرك به
يبدو أن الوقت قد حان
أوو
ثم مفتاح
لذلك بمجرد أن فكرت
[يضحك]
90 كلمة طعمها أفضل من غيرها otl
الرقم العاشر هو بطاقة عباس الحادي والعشرون
لا أستطيع أن أشرب ، لم أستغل هذا التطبيق
أنا آسف ، كنت أبيعه
تدخين ران استنفاد المخدرات من خلال ادعاءات وثغرات
اذا كان ممكنا
اختر وتولى مسؤولية الفريق والرقص
آه
exr sean's hard shell ليس لديه صيف بالفعل
كتابات Art phra mo shoka سخيفة
لم تنم
بادئ ذي بدء ، كانت أكثر رقصة لا تنسى بالأمس
في الآونة الأخيرة ، كان لحمنا dm de
مع أخي الذي يعرف كل شيء وفي الخارج
يرسل مصمم الرقصات
أوه ، أحضر بعض الماء وأعطيني شيئًا كهذا
أوه
الآن ، بدمجه هكذا ،
اعتقد انها صنعت
أراكم مرة أخرى بعد وقت طويل دون علم
المشجعون الذين قدموا هم أيضًا راضون جدًا
وبسبب ذلك ، فإن مصمم الرقصات لا يزال طويل الأمد
لا أتذكر واه مرة أخرى
عن الرقص
قال إنه مستوحى من رقصنا وأشياء أخرى.
شكراً جزيلاً لطلابي الصغار الذين تحدثوا معي
شكرا
حتى أفضل للصغار من هذا القبيل
ليؤثر
جوس رو صعب جدا
هذه هي الطريقة التي يجب أن تصبح من كبار السن فيها
أنا أفكر في أنني سأفعل
أيضا ، أنا آسف ، خادم مناسب جدا
إيتو ، سلم واحد فقط
جسد مثل هذا في الشمس في مركز سيبو الرياضي
آسين منخفض قليلاً في نوايا علاء الدين
ليس لدينا إسهال أو أي شيء أمام جوي
أضفته بكتابته آه
1 لا تطفو ، أنا ألصقها مرة واحدة فقط
ليس من الجيد أن تتجنبها ، لكن i2 أفضل من الربيع
هذا الراديو الأسود ليس مكيف الهواء
تأكد من شراء benteke الشاي
4 صوّر بقوة الآن واستمع إليها
ماي ما هو محتوى بسيط
مع تغير الزمن بسرعة كبيرة
الصراعات بين الأجيال القادمة من هناك
تفكك
إنها كوميديا ​​بشرية.
أنا أعمل بجد على التصوير مرة أخرى.
نعم ، نتطلع إلى ذلك
الدور الذي تريد أن تلعبه
شكرا لك على كل الأدوار
هذا كل شيء
كوهن قايم
رافعة دورة المشاغب آه هذا يكفي المطر
أنا أصنع وأعلم ريو ولا أصنع إلا الجلود
الشعر كلاي لا البيت r لا
الجبال في الظفر المائة 3 4 في اللغة
برج أهاب قرض
الجزائر براءة اختراع Anchor 2 Jeon Galaxy
هل سمعت ذلك؟ 6l 2 أسابيع عدد مفتاح البناء
الشمس ، كثيرا ، شفة متناثرة ، يطير شخص واحد
من يريد إيقاف الكرواسون
منشار
أه في حالتي الشخصية الرئيسية في الحقيقة
القليل من الناس
أعتقد أن لديه شخصية مختلفة ، أليس كذلك؟
لا استطيع ان اقول لكم من هو
لا ولكن هناك العديد من المشاركين الآخرين
لأنه كان هناك أناس ، واحد منهم
بونيرا
[موسيقى]
أحاول أن أعتقد أنه قد يكون مشابهًا
نعم
كنت ألعب الكرات منذ أن كنت صغيراً
الخرزة
هل تذكر
آه
آه جدا
مثال على خادم الإملاء
كنت ألعب الكرات منذ أن كنت صغيراً
من خلال الواقع
لقد صنعت لي حبة
أوه
بدلا من إلقاء اللوم على شيء مشابه لي
فقط
الزيت المتبقي
المعلم ، kkakdugi ، أوه ، ماما ، هذا
يمكن أن يكون سبويلر
لأنه يمكن أن يكون قابس أرضي
كن حذرا
[موسيقى]
هو
أنا أحسدك
لذلك ، الكثير للمراهنة
كن حذرا ، هو
في مهب 4
والمباراة التي أثق فيها
عبور الزجاج
لأنني محظوظ جدا
أنا محظوظ جدا
لقد شعرت به لفترة طويلة ، لكنني محظوظ جدًا
لأنك تعتقد أنك إنسان
أتساءل عما إذا كانت ستصل إلى النهائي
فكر في الأمر 4
في الصباح ، أفكر في شخصية جيدًا
لا استطيع
لا يزال ، الشخصية الأكثر إثارة للإعجاب
اسم الاسم الذي لعبه هاي سو بارك
فيما يلي بعض من أكثرها واقعية
ربما تكون شخصية
لقد تأثرت كثيرا
لأول مرة يقول أن موغونغهوا قد ازدهرت
هناك لعبة خارج
اذهب اذهب يا فتاة
إذا تحركت ، فسوف تعبر البندقية بالفعل
إنها لا تطلق النار ، لكن قبل المباراة الجوية ، إنها كثيرة جدًا
نفسي x لين هوه صوت سول الداخلي
أخشى مثل هذا الصوت ، حتى في كوريا
خط
[موسيقى]
أوه بالإضافة الى
فقط ماذا
يبدو أن أحد الأعضاء كان
من بين هؤلاء الآن ، الأكثر نفوذا
بين الشخصيات
لا أدري، لا أعرف
أه تصبح مجرد لعبة تثق فيها وأنت واثق
نعم ، هذا قادم
يعجبني ، سيد 4 ، أتناوله بسهولة
بثبات
هل يمكنك صنع شكل جيد؟
أريد أن
[موسيقى]
ل
13 عامًا من الموظفين الذين عملوا اليوم وأمس
إنها تنفد
لقد عرفتك منذ وقت طويل جدا
إذا صرخت ، فسيقوم المشجعون
اه رسائل او رسائل عمل
كنت ترسله في كثير من الأحيان. حتى الآن.
لذا مرة أخرى ، نأتي مباشرة
يمكن لبعض الناس رؤيتك وجهًا لوجه
في رأيي ، بطريقة ما ، القليل جدا
إنه لأمر مدهش ، إنه مدهش جدًا
أوه ، أتمنى أن تستمتع بها كثيرًا اليوم
آمل نعم ، هناك العديد من العلامات البارزة في المستقبل
الرجاء دعم لي 4
لكن شكرا
[موسيقى]